it just a little bit of background on
Jena Madea I think this is helpful for
those that that aren't really working on
these tools every day so this is a
naturally occurring system you would not
believe how many billions of copies of
this are in this room right now they're
part of our microbiomes and our microbes
if you imagine the market cap on this
and how much you're worth
it's it's really kind of fun to think
about and see that math but but the way
these systems developer it's it's a way
for bacteria to have an immune system so
they don't have antibodies and white
blood cells to help them defend against
infection but what they do have is is
CRISPR caste system so a virus here this
this little guy in the top corner and
serves as DNA into the bacterial to
attack it and that bacteria can cut up
that viral DNA make a copy of it and
insert that almost in a like a library
into its own genome as a memory of that
infection so that it's offspring the
next time they're infected with a virus
it'll say okay I have a copy of this
virus I've seen it before I'm going to
cut it up and neutralize it so this is
this is a defense and what was the big
really innovation about five years ago
Jennifer Doudna Fong Jung and others
recognized that instead of using this
viral DNA what you could do is program
any piece of DNA that you want as a
guide to take this editor to a place
that you'd like to in the genome and
using editing parlance you could delete
a gene or you can copy/paste and insert
a new gene this is an incredibly
powerful technology so let's start to
think about what do surprise look like
what's the sputnik of this type of work
so thinking of a bacterial system what
could be maybe program in Mass into a
bacteria enter George Church and of
course he has taken every single picture
in this moving image and mapped a genome
sequence to it uploaded that sequence in
the rapid upload time of about three
days into a bacteria and this is this is
on a loop it's a very short segment but
each and every one of those pixels has
been programmed into a DNA and that your
readout from that system is is
sequencing that bacteria
so this is starting to show you what
these technologies may enable one day is
it DNA data storage well the the price
of synthesis isn't yet at a price point
that this is realistic in the next year
or two but maybe in the next 10 or 20
years it is realistic there's a window
of opportunity here that we can start to
build in encryption systems ways that we
can start to to protect this information
if we want to as a nation use these
technologies beyond that it turns out
that CRISPR Cassadine is almost like a
one-size-fits-all editor i I don't think
Chris forecast has met an organism yet
that it can't edit so from salamanders
to pigs to rodents to bacteria when you
start to think about what we can edit
now we can think of editing these things
as systems as maybe entire ecosystems
may be creating new ecosystems of the
future or reviving ecosystems from the
past learning from them there's folks in
this room that are interested in indie
extinction bringing back things like the
woolly mammoth out of the context of
their original ecosystem maybe it makes
sense to not only bring back the woolly
mammoth but the plant life that that
woolly mammoth may have enjoyed so
thinking about the extinction there is a
time sometimes as a society that we
decide to eliminate something from our
environment smallpox is one example of
something that that we have eliminated
because of the incredible suffering and
death that brought two individuals
countries still maintain stockpiles for
for fear of resurgence and you may have
heard recently that Canadian researchers
actually reconstituted an extinct pox
virus in this case it was a horse pox
virus which had also been eradicated as
an agricultural pest it had not been
detected anywhere in the wild since the
1980s and so as a society collectively
we have eradicated these species of
virus and the one individual or small
group of individuals has made the
decision to bring that pox virus back so
I want to emphasize that the power of
small groups of individuals here using
these technologies is immense
it's important that we get the word out
thinking about you know I'm not sure if
somebody said in this context what could
possibly go wrong if we bring back a
horse Fox virus and you know it's funny
but it's not funny
you know how do we address this going
forward and I you know again emphasizing
thinking about the power of one genome
editors can be applied to even bias the
outcomes of inheritance and something
that's called a gene Drive what a gene
Drive does is it couples a trait of
interest with a genome editor in this
case if you want to suppress something
like a mosquito that's a carrier of
vector-borne diseases like malaria or
dengue you can couple the traits that
say that makes a mosquito resistant to
to malaria with CRISPR castes and so
through reproduction it makes a copy of
itself into the the sister chromosome
chromosome so where mom and dad each
would have a different copy now dads
copy gets copied into mom's coffee and
and there's there's a hundred percent
inheritance of your trait of interest so
for something like vector borne disease
you may want to use a tool like this and
people have heralded okay we now have
the technology to destroy all Zika
mosquitos or name your favorite
vector-borne disease but at the same
time we have now created for the first
time a tool that can lead to extinction
so under what circumstances do we decide
to use this tool and understand you know
how this might work in the environment
and you know is there a way to do this
in it in a measured way that maybe can
do a local extinction and not a global
extinction these are some of the
questions that I brought to the
community to ask you know how can we
move forward safely in this world and
then finally of course human uses of
these technologies there's a lot of
people are afraid to use the c-word the
Cure word for cancerous here but it
really looks like application of these
technologies through some T cell
therapies and otherwise can reverse
cancer even at very late stages industry
that makes transgenic organisms for
research tools use these same exact
reagents to cause disease in animal
I don't think you need to be a
biosecurity experts you recognize that
there is a need for scrutiny when you
look at a tool that can both cure and
cause that is and cause a disease